let me just bring you a quick bit of
breaking news we understand from the GMB
Union that more than 10 000 ambulance
workers have voted to strike they say
across nine trusts across England and
Wales at the GMB union says that no one
in the Health Service takes strike
action lightly today shows just how
desperate they are that from the GMB
Union they say that a paramedic
paramedics emergency care assistance
call handlers and other staff are now
set to walk out in a number of trusts to
name a few of them Southwest Ambulance
Service Southeast Coast Ambulance
Service Northwest Ambulance Service
South Central Northeast East Midlands
West Midlands Welsh and Yorkshire
ambulance services as well and they say
that workers across the ambulance
services and some NHS trusts have voted
to strike over the government's imposed
four percent pay award they describe
this as a another massive real terms pay
card and they go on to say that the GMB
will now meet with representatives in
the next couple of days to discuss
potential strike dates before Christmas
so that's the latest from the GMB they
say 10 000 ambulance workers have voted
to strike or have all the details coming
up next